eu cometi um erro não o quadro de
pessoal de quem fala é o lugar que sejam
muito bem vindos já é mais fiel eu os
estragos e que iria j oz e é é é como o
magic mouse é esta tac fun já estou a
contar se agredindo nem que vocês querem
agora tinham bom este é um daqueles
filmes de finais 7 fredes mas que este
tem uma particularidade é e eu estava na
região onde em 4.013 pontos sereno e não
saímos tabu é realista e só já estava em
frente à porta da sua mãe a chuveiro que
a primeira que o ambiente de toulon no
mundo agora eu acho eu o andrés tio que
nós temos a opção para escolher angeli
combate que vem ai ai
merian o gol - cada um 11 anos mudou meu
deus que ele está agora a chegar aqui o
tj assim o opa que o aproxima do frete
em um tatu preto jogou a pedra isto tem
um núcleo homem nu outro aí chegar na
casa olha só como está realista meu deus
acho que um dia o mundo aqui
a etapa que ficava à frente está fora
rocha ficou de fora porque o time tem
sempre as musiquinhas de jassan aqui
dentro da ilha era o kelvin já se quer
sair daqui
a maré não está muito é muito ruído
muita confusão já pra mim eu posso
sentir após posso passar se no irã entre
o povoado chuva é mesmo esquema
a porta fechou a porta ao piso
alô a lei fala do rei
fred não é somar é só uma luta 11 uma
batata doce e este ano reforça agora meu
deus tapuia enviá lo nesse que é o fred
seu bom nome e não a faz toma dirigindo
já expulsos no jogo pronto ok já possuí
não há que ter medo agora é só olhar em
frente e tentar fugir do fred cunha
sofreu alto bicho grande como as duas
contra o voto porque - não assina tão
pequeno ao lado do fred
agora o que eu tenho que fazer eu não
seu objetivo visto após também ter sido
da casa e apanhar qualquer coisa e não
sei e não sei se daqui
ai ai meu deus meu deus mil e de
perseguições pessoal é coisa mais [ __ ]
que vocês podem pôr um jogo meu porque é
coisa de burro vindo está porque é pra
cá
calma calma calma calma está pior do 4s
o atleta até agora foi o jogo que eu
tive mais perseguições né
foi o que eu joguei com as perseguições
isso aqui tá pior e sou uma não é só uma
vez aquilo chance na que vai resultar em
informações não postar tudo chavo claro
quarto de chave em tudo juntar tudo
chavo um chapéu hellcat hábito ea não
para com essas piadas dúvida um
limãozinho à frente ai caramba é quem
para o fred wesley também não pode ser
de uma pessoa na minha
houve um leão robótico aquilo não fugir
do senac oferece o médio é essa salvagem
sá
frank silvestrin é ayew carro e fosse
boy
tomou jabiraca prius é hoje é hoje que é
que vai provar duas vezes foi outra vez
para lá existem instruções têm um
tutorial não tem uma lei
o assunto 3
o foco total nenhum com ele por mais que
eu mostre aproximaram dos frades
eu sei que aqui aporta baixar agora ele
já sai esta parte mesmo assim susto
porque coisas acontecem na vila fazem as
pessoas têm ações de cultura diz ele não
sair é um mito a falar por mim isto
funciona - sua comenta a isso vocês
viram o vídeo até aqui cometem aí o que
eu tenho que fazer para passar esta esta
coisa e não sai o objetivo disto eu não
vi nada sobre o jogo não vi nada eu só
vou jogar porque vocês nunca viram
obrigados a casa trabalha aí a casa do
mainz kraft x não acaba
vai pagá los a superar o sufragaram luz
e um vestido verde faz sentido faz muito
sentido o caiu agora tem que por onde eu
não sei só uma viriato
vai com calma agora inspira na esquina
lá eu acho que aqui pra esquerda que
deve haver qualquer coisa não tá em nada
luta divertidas do jogo que vai
construir encarar não sabem transmitir
outra pagar luz para ai ai o meu pai que
ele estar dinheiro no banco j
acho que o país já que o país é meu eu
tenho que pôr onde eu tenho que abrir
uma porta e não só a esta porta aqui uma
curtinha grupo tinha não funciona nada
aqui é preciso uma chave
eu não sei não dá pra apanhar nada tá
tudo bem tá tranquilo e favorável do
país o álbum chegar porque com estes
vídeos pra vocês tenham gostado claro
que vocês gostaram claro não esqueçam
explicado aí nos comentários o que tem
que fazer neste jogo este é um alfa
ainda por isso é provável que não haja
mesmo nada pra fazer mechas se houver
digamos comentários que é isso quando o
aspecto bonito fica meio assim né